une partie du plaisir est le fait que nous
ne savons pas qui il est
[Musique]
vous pensez que le mystère de l'identité de banky
évoluera
un jour mais le fait que vous posiez
cette question pourrait signifier que c'est vous
n'est-ce pas
[Musique]
avoir une situation politiquement répressive
contre laquelle réagir est extrêmement
important pour de nombreux artistes. Les
dommages causés aux trains signifient une perturbation du
Londres plus large pour nous tous.
tous les
meilleurs murs sont à Los Angeles
c'est vraiment triste de voir que c'est parti
et c'est devenu un peu un point de repère je
pense ici
[Musique]
allez à l'intérieur
je pense qu'il n'y a aucun doute où se situent ses
convictions politiques
mais  le vrai génie de banky est
sa
capacité à réduire ce débat incroyablement
complexe
en une seule
image simple